are they starting to steal our Thunder
the Germans well I'm really pleased that
Germany itself is advancing its own
defense posture because of its culture
its history and so forth that it's been
hesitant to build up its own Armed
Forces so it is investing it's buying
f-35s it's recognizing that there's some
European security to be done and Germany
wants to participate in that but you
highlight an important point is the fact
that whilst we are ever more assertive
in what we're doing and we've done a
brilliant job in Ukraine our defense
budget has remained on a peacetime
setting and the defense uh the committee
have been arguing for some time that we
now need to recognize our world is
moving into more dangerous places it's
getting more complex so threats are
growing we do need to upgrade how much
we spend on defense and what does the
defense secretary say to you when you um
call him out on it well he says he's you
know putting his case to the treasury
itself we need to keep making the case
there's an absolute connectivity to our
economy and to the security you can't
separate the two now half of our GDP is
exposed to International headwinds how
many times have you and I spoken about
those grain Ships coming out of Ukraine
that's all to do with providing
necessary security Britain is a leader
in NATO we're a leader in the
Commonwealth as well certainly a leader
in European security too we can only do
that if we have the hard power to match
as well uh Navy is half the size as it
needs to be our army has shrunk we need
to invest in tanks in armored fighting
vehicles and so forth and of course
there's other dimensions of the battle
space such as cyber and space which we
are investing into but because we've
invested there we've capped the other
three services as well so we've had this
defense review refresh over the last
couple of months at the end of June we
will then see how this will impact on
our defense posture itself okay
um how are you feeling about the
compromise that Rishi sunax seems to
have come up with with uh president
zielinski when it comes to aircraft it
is difficult the typhoon is not the best
aircraft for them to have the F-16 is
clearly the one that they should be
using there are Mig fighter pilots
Ukrainian Pilots that within three
months could be using those I hope that
we can exert our influence to encourage
the Americans to step forward it could
be that as with the the tanks we offered
uh Challenger two battle tanks again
they weren't appropriate the leopard
tank was more appropriate but the fact
that we then did it showed the political
courage others followed so perhaps you
know maybe we could get those we have 30
trance one typhoons maybe we could start
uh providing those they're not ideal
because they're air-to-air combat rather
than at a ground which is what required
but it's absolutely fundamental
president zlinski was here with carrying
his helmet when he visited Parliament to
say this is what I require if you want
to punch through Russian defenses using
tanks that they're now getting they need
the top cover with the fast Jets okay um
I was spirited lunch yesterday where two
well-known peers were going at each
other in a very friendly way about
brexit and it came up as part of the
conversation that Nigel farage says that
brexit is broken oh my goodness I I'm
fascinating to hear this who wanted
brexit more than anybody else in the
country this was Nigel farage this is
what he's lived for his entire life so
he clearly had a plan as to what brexit
would look like and I would agree with
him that what we've ended up is not
there what Nigel farage wanted to do and
he campaigned for this is to stay in the
single market now it wasn't just him it
was also Boris Johnson it was Dan Hannon
and it was David Frost as well these
were the big architects of the believe
effort now we ended up with an extreme
form of brexit now he's saying oh it's
not working I think he should put it up
his hand a little bit and say why didn't
he stick to his guns and encourage the
nation to keep going and end up with the
place where he originally wanted to be
don't encourage him
um should we be very quickly encouraging
this trust to wander the world's stage
as she is oh what a question I we need
to recognize and it fits in with some of
the other strange conventions that are
taking place uh you know across Britain
at the moment under a conservative
Banner as such that this is all seen the
Optics have seen as to whether this
supports the current prime minister or
not whether it's Boris Johnson or Liz
trust everything that they will do will
be looked at to see whether it's
supportive of our chances to win the
next general election we've entered a
period of calm we've entered a period of
determination we're closing in the polls
when you see somebody like Liz trust go
to Taiwan the Chinese won't distinguish
the fact that this is a former prime
minister operating on their own they'll
see this as antagonistic going against
the will of the current prime minister